OK.
Quick story.
I'm not going to spend a lot of time on this
one.
Yesterday, Fox News had a big get for their
primetime show.
HANNITY with propagandist Sean HANNITY.
The big get.
Was Donald Trump.
And they were bragging about it all day, promoting
it, promoting it tonight.
Trump.
9:00 p.m. Eastern.
Don't miss it.
And it was one of the most immoral interviews
I've maybe ever seen on the network with Donald
Trump.
Trump was not just allowed, but he was encouraged
to tell lies, to brag about things that are
actually bad.
And we have to look at at least a few pieces
of this.
So while Trump has failed daily in his Corona
virus, press briefings in his Corona virus
leadership, New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
has actually been doing a pretty damn good
job.
Now, you don't have to like Andrew Cuomo.
You don't have to agree with some of the things
Andrew Cuomo has done in the past with regard
to budgets and benefits or whatever.
Andrew Cuomo is taking this seriously.
He's being a leader.
His almost daily updates provide actual data
and facts rather than hyperbolic bragging.
So who does Trump go after during the interview
with HANNITY?
Course he goes after Andrew Cuomo because
Trump can't stand sharing the spotlight with
anybody.
Here is Trump saying Andrew Cuomo is effectively
clueless, criticizing Cuomo for not praising
Donald Trump.
Well, I'm a diplomat, too.
You know, since I've become president, I have
to view things a little bit differently.
Look, Andrew, I've known him a long time.
Is a hard time getting the words out.
Thank you.
You did a great job, but he's been pretty
good over the last week or so.
It's starting out.
I'm right, because they wanted 40000 ventilators,
40000.
They're not going to need anywhere near that.
We said that.
And now they have plenty.
And if they needed someone, we can bring them
some more because we have a stockpile that
we've built up and that we have for emergency.
So.
But, you know, we built the largest hospital
in the country in four days.
Trump's attention deficit issues actually
seem more pronounced during these phone interviews.
I imagine Trump is sitting there on the phone,
but he's watching TV at the same time.
He's looking at other things while doing the
interview.
And of course, any Trump HANNITY interview
at this point in the Corona virus crisis has
to include talking about chloroquine as the
miracle corona virus treatment that both Donald
Trump and HANNITY have been promoting.
They've both been on that train for a while.
And of course, it does come up during the
interview.
And by the way, the hydroxy chloroquine.
We have millions of doses that I bought.
I bought millions of doses, you know, for
the country.
The country bought twenty nine million action.
We have more than twenty nine million doses.
Now, I'm not going to play like a ton more
of this because you're probably getting a
sense of how insane it all is.
But here's another whacked out moment Trump
admits during the interview.
And this is I mean, this this is the type
of thing where we should really be crying
about it, but we sort of laugh to avoid crying.
Trump admits during the interview that he's
getting his information about who needs ventilators,
not from the states, not from health officials,
not from governors.
Trump is getting ventilator data by watching
Fox News and Sean HANNITY.
Take a listen to this.
The number of beds needed.
I think we were right about that.
I was right.
My group was right there, not needing nearly
as many beds, badges.
So after not needing as many ventilators as
they thought.
In fact, we just saw.
In fact, I just saw in your show, a couple
of other people just reported back to me that
everyone is in great shape from the standpoint
of ventilators, which are very hard because
they're expensive and they're big like it's
a nuts and they're very high tech, but they're
very hard to get.
And we're building thousands of them and we
have that in good shape.
I saw on your show, Trump says, and people
reported to me about your show, how great
everything is going with ventilators.
Trump is openly, actively ignoring what actual
health experts and governors are saying, and
he's bragging about it on national television.
Just imagine how backwards this world we live
in has become, or at least how backwards our
government has become.
We are now really in Idiocracy.
I mean, it is that term that most accurately
assesses where we are a little more from this
interview and you're probably starting to
feel a little sick to your stomach from the
insanity.
Of course, Trump has to attack the media during
the interview.
And here he does, saying all coverage of his
Corona virus response has been unfair.
It's been bad, kind of as a wrap up to this
complete disinformation propaganda interview
with Sean HANNITY about which Fox News bragged
all day, which was in the last 20 seconds.
I have your relationship a little bit better
with the media.
Hasn't been great.
We have 20 seconds.
Now, it hasn't been very good.
I think the thing if we could just have if
we had an honest media, our country would
be the greatest beneficiary.
The media has been the lamestream media has
been extremely dishonest.
And it's a shame.
It's very sad.
Mr. President, I know I share this with the
American people.
We want you to succeed.
We want the American people healthy.
We want this economy growing as fast as possible.
Thank you, sir.
We appreciate your time.
John, thank you.
So there it is, another softball whacked out
Fox News interview.
And I think this is you know, we talk about
how those low media literacy in this country,
a lot of people can't distinguish news reporting
from opinion.
And Fox News preys on people who can't distinguish
between news reporting and opinion.
This interview can't even really count as
journalism.
We know Trump and HANNITY speak privately.
They are friends.
They help each other's propaganda.
And really, when HANNITY interviews Trump,
it's not journalism.
It's more of an infomercial.
I don't know if you've seen those infomercials
that are structured like like news shows.
And there will be someone sitting at a desk.
Larry King has actually done some of these
and it looks like it's a journalistic interview,
but it's a paid host who is there to make
the seller of a product or service look good.
That's what it is.
When HANNITY interviews Donald Trump and unfortunately,
if you just look online, look on Twitter,
look on, you know, those on Cleeves of the
Internet riddled with Trump supporters.
They see this interview and they believe it
is journalism.
They believe it is a real interview where
Sean HANNITY presses Trump to give us information
and the media literacy issue that continues
to plague this country.
It's really the score bridge to quote Donald
Trump or the scourge that is really something
that is only fomenting support of Donald Trump
because people can't even figure out what
it is that's going on.
And it's a very, very sad thing.